this is one of the most important days
in Brazil's recent political history
battle between the right and the left
Rio is one of the key centers in this
election winning here is vital
president bolsonaro has major support in
Rio and this is why
[Applause]
Evangelical white consider bolsonaro
their president and their Guardian
over 30 percent of Brazilians are
evangelists their support is Rock Solid
[Music]
um
across the country there have been long
lines of people voting
there's a sense that the country's deep
divisions are coming to a head
but it would be extremely unusual for
there to be a first round winner but of
course it is actually a possibility
there's a lot of people turning out to
vote and that is a distinct Advantage
for Lula it means they're coming from
the favelas coming down to town and
casting their votes there's a big
turnout in support of him then he could
win this first round
certainly the people we spoke to are
hoping that there will be a first round
winner many at this polling station
tended towards Lula
but nothing in this election is ever
certain
many don't even want to say who they'll
vote for I don't like neither of them
because
I don't like bolsonaro because what he
represents for the country is very bad
because he's homophobic he doesn't like
women and everything but Lula also was
arrested and I don't like him as well so
so that's the choice though yes
people are eager for a decisive vote and
an acceptance of the result
whoever wins will do so knowing Brazil
is badly divided and will need to heal
take you live to Rio De Janeiro now and
our chief respondent there Stuart Ramsey
um Stuart what can you tell us what what
are we hearing about who's out front are
there exit polls
no there's no exit polls this year the
reason being it's electronic system so
it comes out really really quickly now
it has been slightly delayed it is a new
system so you know I think it's taken
slightly longer for people to cast their
votes also there's been a really big
turnout so there is a slight delay but
we would expect
those results to come through in the
next hour maybe uh two hours so I would
say this there have been two polls at
the end which put Lula at 51 and 50 plus
a vote now that means he would win uh in
the first round it's very very unusual
here for that to happen but I think that
Lulu's people think they have actually
done it the those polls are also putting
bolsonaro in the mid 30s so it's long
long way behind uh Lula he just needs to
try and get over that uh 50 uh Mark what
happens next we don't really know I mean
you can assume that his if he does win
in this in this round and it will if not
by the way it just goes all the way to
the end of the month there's a lot of
concern about political violence in that
Gap so lot of people are hoping that
this actually happens then it's uh
president bolsonaro himself he's he's
often said on record he doesn't believe
that the voting system is fair and it's
going to be rigged very much like
President Trump so we'll have to see
what his attitude is like but if it's a
thumping Victory uh falula it'll be very
difficult for him to say I just simply
don't believe it and refuse to take part
but really it's quite tense here I mean
it we're in Rio it looks lovely and
everything and there's people in those
bars as you can imagine but it is quite
tense that this could turn uh Nazi and
as I say we should get those results in
the next hour or two